China es el país más contaminante del mundo
y también el mayor consumidor de energía.
Seguro que esto no os pilla por sorpresa,
¿verdad?
Pues precisamente por este motivo, el gigante
asiático juega un papel clave para que se
puedan cumplir los objetivos climáticos del
Acuerdo de París, un acuerdo que busca limitar
a un máximo de 2 grados el calentamiento
global.
Y en toda esta operación reducir el uso del
carbón para producir energía es algo fundamental.
Siguiendo el propio Acuerdo de París este
tipo de combustión debería eliminarse para
el año 2050 en todo el mundo.
(A día de hoy, China emite el 30% de todas
las emisiones de Co2.
Sin embargo, al mismo tiempo el gigante asiático
supone el 20% de todas las manufacturas globales.
Es decir, China sigue siendo muy ineficiente
a la hora de gestionar la contaminación.
Y esto es algo que tiene mucho que ver con
su alta dependencia del carbón como combustible
para sus centrales eléctricas.
El carbón es un medio muy barato para producir
energía y China posee reservas de carbón
a punta pala.
Y sí, hace no mucho se hizo creer al mundo
que estas centrales, llamémosle sucias, iban
a tener los días [o los años] contados,
eso ahora ya no está tan claro.)
Queridos amigos de VisualPolitik. Sigilosamente,
China parece haber dado marcha atrás al compromiso
que el propio Xi Jinping lanzó hace poco
tiempo. O… al menos, lo ha frenado en seco.
En este vídeo os vamos a contar cómo y por
qué China ha decidido mirar de perfil al
problema de contaminación que supone el carbón
y también que podemos esperar.
¡Atentos!
Fijaos en estas dos noticias. Tienen una diferencia
de tan solo tres años.
(2016 - China advierte a Trump contra el abandono
del acuerdo sobre el cambio climático - Financial Times)
(2019 - Años después de congelar nuevos
proyectos, China vuelve a construir plantas
de carbón - The Washington Post)
¿Sorprendidos?
Pues… No deberiais. Xi Jinping eso de predicar
con el ejemplo no lo lleva del todo bien.
Es cierto que se han producido avances, pero
hoy por hoy el divorcio entre China y el carbón
es algo que genera muchos pero que muchos
interrogantes.
China sigue siendo un país en vias de desarrollo
y por tanto su demanda de energía no solo
empujada por la industria sino también por
su pujante clase medida crece y crece sin
parar.
Literalmente China devora energía.
Es decir, China aún está muy lejos de llegar
al punto en el que estamos por ejemplo en
Europa, dónde con energías más limpias
y mejoras de eficiencia podemos aspirar a
mantener a raya tanto el consumo energético
como las emisiones de Co2.
Todo lo contrario a lo que ocurre en China.
De hecho, a pesar de las promesas y los diferentes
planes del gobierno del gobierno chino, este
país no solo no está reduciendo su producción
eléctrica con carbón sino que incluso la
está incrementando. Y con ella las emisones.
Las emisiones chinas ligadas al carbón crecen
cada año.
¿Queréis más detalles?
(CHINA Y EL CARBÓN ¿EL DIVORCIO IMPOSIBLE?)
Amigos en la relación de China con el carbón
hay un hecho determinante: Hoy por hoy China,
simplemente no puede - y tampoco quiere - dejar
de producir energía a partir del carbón.
No puede. Da igual lo que te hayan contado, no va a ocurrir.
Os lo contábamos al principio.
El gran gigante asiático ha vuelto a permitir
la construcción de centrales termoeléctricas
de carbón en al menos 11 provincias.
Y no creáis que estamos hablando de una,
ni dos, ni tres centrales nuevas. Ni siquiera
de diez.
Hablamos del desbloqueo de al menos dos docenas
de nuevas centrales, algunas de ellas enormes,
que incrementarán la producción energética
china por carbón en 150 gigavatios. Para
que os hagais una idea es prácticamente la
producción eléctrica con carbón de toda
la Unión Europea.
Y no solo eso. Para abastecer todas esas nuevas
centrales está previsto que en los próximos
años se abran 40 nuevas minas de carbón.
Es decir, se crearan miles de puestos de trabajo
vinculados a esta industria.
Y hablamos tan solo de un par de años.
Ahora bien, un momento. ¿Significa esto que
China le ha dado definitivamente la espalda
a su compromiso de reducir la contaminación?
¿Qué lo único que podemos esperar es a que China contamine más, más y más?
Pues no, no exactamente, no del todo. Al menos,
siempre y cuando hablemos en términos relativos,
claro. Fijaos.
(Desde el 2012, el porcentaje del mix energético
producido por carbón ha caído del 68,5%
al 59% en 2018.
En 6 años, China ha pasado de producir con
carbón más de dos tercios de toda su energía
a poco más de la mitad. Sigue siendo un porcentaje
enorme, pero la reducción es considerable
y ese es, precisamente, el dato que utiliza
el gobierno para sacar pecho.)
Pero claro, que China haya reducida su dependencia
del carbón en 10 puntos… pues no parece
una cifra como para echar las campanas al
vuelo. Sobre todo si tenemos en cuenta que…
¿realmente importan los datos relativos cuándo
hablamos de contaminación? ¿Qué importa
la distribución del mix si eso significa
que las emisiones derivadas del carbón continuan
aumentado?
Pensadlo un momento.
Imaginad que la energía total producida por
China un año es 1000 y unos años más tarde
pasa a ser digamos de 1500 unidades de energía.
Pues bien, supongamos que primero se producían
700 de esas 1000 unidades con carbón, y años
después se producen con carbón 900 de 1500.
Técnicamente sí, se habría reducido el
peso del carbón en la producción total energética,
pero la realidad es que la producción de
energía con carbón habría aumentado en
200.
Y si hablamos de contaminación, emisiones
y medio ambiente, lo que importa son las cifras
absolutas.
Y, amigos, eso es precisamente lo que está
ocurriendo en China.
Como podéis ver, en lo que llevamos de milenio
China ha multiplicado por 5 la producción
de electricidad con carbón, mientras que
en mismo periodo Estados Unidos y la Unión
Europea la han reducido sensiblemente.
Ahora bien, un momento, antes de dictar sentencia.
Si os digo que China además de líder mundial
en energía sucia también es líder mundial
en energía limpia, ¿cómo os quedáis?
Pues… idlo digiriendo porque de hecho es
exactamente así. En cifras absolutas, China
produce más energía con fuentes limpias
que ningún otro país del planeta.
728 gigavatios instalados en 2018 producidos
con energías renovables, un 12% más que
en 2017.
Pero… ¿Pero, entonces, cómo es esto posible?
¿Por qué demonios siguen construyendo centrales
de carbón en lugar de ponerle punto y final
a esa tecnología definitivamente?
Pues, lo cierto es que sobre esta cuestión
hay todo un conflicto interno. China, literalmente
flota en carbón. Su subsuelo está repleto
de este mineral.
(Hay regiones que, sin el carbón, de la noche
a la mañana volverían a la pobreza absoluta.
Hablamos de decenas de miles de trabajadores,
cientos de miles de trabajadores que comen
de este sector: mineros, trabajadores de las
centrales, transportistas, etcétera.
El problema por tanto está en lo que supondría
para China eliminar el mercado interno del
carbón, hoy por hoy un sector esencial para
poder mantener una producción de bajo coste
capaz de competir en los mercados internacionales)
Y es aquí dónde nos surge una gran cuestión,
la pregunta clave: ¿Será capaz China de
cumplir los plazos marcados por la comunidad
internacional para combatir las emisiones
de gases de efecto invernadero? ¿Realmente
logrará sustituir su dependencia del carbón?
(EL PARADIGMA CHINO: DE LA AMBICIÓN A LA
REALIDAD)
Amigos, el caso de China es un poco más complicado
de lo que parece. Cómo veis, en este país
eso de dejar de construir centrales contaminantes
y pasar a depender de renovables no es algo
tan sencillo.
Pero el problema no es nuevo, viene de lejos.
(En la década de 1980, como todos sabéis,
China vivió una explosión industrial y económica
brutal. Evidentemente, todo eso se vio acompañado
de una demanda de energía también brutal.
Y poder satisfacer una demanda tan alta y
con tanto crecimiento interanual es muy complicado.
Las centrales de producción de energía tardan
tiempo en construirse y en entrar en servicio,
sin embargo la energía se necesitaba ya,
la demanda era instantánea.
No se podía esperar meses, años hasta que
las centrales estuvieran listas.)
Precisamente por eso el gobierno chino promovió
leyes que permitieran a las empresas y a los
gobiernos regionales adelantarse a la demanda
y construir muchas más centrales de carbón
de las necesarias.
Porque, al fin y al cabo, con esa tendencia
de demanda energética creciente, se iban
a necesitar más pronto que tarde, ¿no os
parece?
Pues bien, hace relativamente poco tiempo,
en 2014 el gobierno central permitió a sus
provincias aprobar y construir centrales eléctricas.
Es decir, descentralizó la toma de decisiones.
Y esto… digamos que no fue una idea demasiado
buena… NO si hablamos de sustituir al carbón.
(Veréis, los gobernantes de las provincias
chinas suelen ser personas que buscan dar
el salto a la esfera política nacional y
hacer carrera en el partido para llegar a
ocupar altos cargos en el gobierno central.
Qué es dónde está el poder, el dinero y
la influencia.
Pero para eso tienen que demostrar ciertas
aptitudes, una capacidad de gestión destacable.
En el modelo chino los resultados cuentan
así que tienen que lograr que su provincia
se desarrolle, a ser posible más rapido que
el resto.
Por eso, los gobiernos provinciales hacen
todo lo posible y lo imposible para alimentar
la industrialización de sus regiones. Industrialización
que, cómo no, va acompañado de mucha, mucha
energía…. y por tanto, cómo veis, con
carbón)
Todo parece un win-win, siempre que nos olvidemos
del medio ambiente y en el caso de los chinos
estén dispuestos a salir a la calle con una
mascarilla conectada a una bombona de oxígeno,
porque, amigos, la polución en las ciudades
chinas es un problema de verdad.
Y claro, ante semejante percal [imaginaos
la imagen internacional que daba China con
este percal en plena psicosis climática]
el gobierno central se dio cuenta del error
y revirtió, como os contábamos al principio
del vídeo, la construcción de un montón
de nuevas centrales en 2016.
Paralización que, ahora, se ha paralizado.
[Valga la redundancia, vaya]. En gran medida
para tratar de estimular así una economía
que en los últimos años se ha desacelerado.
Y China cada vez que el crecimiento se desacelera
lo que hace el gobierno es gastar miles y
miles de millones en todo tipo de proyectos.
Y ahí es dónde entra precisamente la enorme
inversión en grandes centrales de carbón
y también en renovables.
Literalmente montañas y montañas recubiertas
de paneles solares, coronadas con aerogeneradores
y, en sus ríos, represas para la producción
hidroeléctrica. ¿Sabéis la salvajada de
dinero que está costando eso?
Pues agarraos. De los 289.000 millones de
dólares invertidos en energías renovables
a nivel mundial en 2018, sólo China invirtió
más de 91.000, más del 31%.
Sabiendo esto no debería extrañarnos que
algunos lugares de China hayan desarrollado
un paisaje 100% artificial pero también 100%
energéticamente sostenible.
Y gracias a esos paisajes tan… ¿disruptivos?
es por lo que China ha conseguido, por ejemplo,
estas buenas cifras en 2019.
(La capacidad de las energía renovable en
China aumenta un 9,5% interanual en junio
- Reuters)
Así que no, si pensábais que no era posible
ser sucio y limpio al mismo tiempo, os equivocábais.
Un mix eléctrico que si fuera una persona
tendría un claro trastorno de bipolaridad
Pero volvamos a la gran pregunta… ¿Podrá
China superar su adicción al carbón?
(La demanda de energía en China crece tan
rápido que a pesar de la enorme inversión
acometida por el gobierno central, las renovables
no es que no puedan ya sustituir otros tipos
de energía más contaminantes, sino que difícilmente
pueden cubrir todo el crecimiento de la demanda.
Y es precisamente ahí donde nos encontramos
con la otra gran apuesta del gobierno chino:
la energía nuclear.
Fijaos, actualmente China cuenta con 46 reactores
operativos y otros 11 en construcción.
Pero eso es tan solo el comienzo.
Recientemente la Corporación Tecnológica
Estatal de Energía Nuclear ha anunciado que
el país construirá al menos otros 60 reactores
nucleares durante la próxima década.
De momento 43 ya están planificados, aprobados
y cuentan ya con la financiación necesaria
para llevar a cabo su construcción.
Y eso no es todo, además se han propuesto
formalmente otros 136 proyectos para su estudio.
Al fin y al cabo, hablamos de un país donde
la energía nuclear no es ni mucho menos un
tema tabú.
De hecho, en China podemos encontrar iniciativas
tan curiosas como la del China General Nuclear
Power Group (CGN), que ha llegado a invitar
a parejas a celebrar su boda ni más ni menos
que en la central nuclear de Daya Bay en Shenzhen.
Eso sí, a cambio de publicar sus fotos en
la red.
Amigos, China está apostando fuerte por la
energía nuclear para complementar a las renovables.
Y tened una cosa presente: hoy por hoy esa
vía parece la única posible para que el
gigante asiático reduzca su adicción al
carbón.)
En fin amigos, llegados a este punto turno
para ti:
¿Qué piensas? ¿puede China abandonar efectivamente
el carbón, dejar de construir centrales y
empezar a desmantelarlas, mientras siga creciendo
su industria?
¿Llegará a ser China vista algún día como
ejemplo de energías limpias en lugar de como
un lugar humeante y ambientalmente hostil?
¿Qué pensáis de la cancelación de la paralización
de las nuevas centrales de carbón que suponen
una marcha atrás de los compromisos de China
en el Acuerdo de París?
Dejadnos vuestras opiniones aquí abajo, en
los comentarios, que ya sabéis que nos encanta
leeros, tanto como nos encanta que le deis
like si os ha gustado este vídeo y os suscribais
a nuestro canal para no perderos los que están
por venir.